[Music]
the hurricane was due to return to port
on Sunday instead it went up in flames
and three British Nationals are now
missing
12 other British tourists as well as 10
crew members were rescued off the coast
of Masa Alam in Egypt
a foreign office spokesperson said we
are in contact with local authorities
following an incident aboard a dive boat
near Mata Alam and are supporting
British Nationals involved
authorities say the blaze was sparked by
an electrical problem and it comes only
a few days after 36 people were rescued
from a speedboat which sank in the Red
Sea the company which the missing divers
would have booked through insist the
hurricane has never had any problems
we have as through the travel we have
worked with the the operator of the of
the of the vessel for since about 2001
very good operators so we'll be
interested to see what the what the
investigation comes uh
this fire is bad news for Egypt's
tourism industry but it will be mostly
felt by the families of the missing
divers
Alice Porter Sky News